now that we've set up our our equations
let's see if we can answer some more
interesting questions and just as a
warm-up we're going to do a little bit
of what we did in the last video but
i'll do it with the equations now the
equations really are just a mathematical
representation of the same information
that we had up here so as a starting
point let's think about how much under
the basic plan let's think about how
much it will cost for us to attend three
sessions in a given month
well we've got our equation right over
here our total cost in that month is
going to be equal to 20
20 plus 8
plus 8
plus 8 times the number of sessions the
number of sessions is s s is 3 in the
circumstance so we'll replace the s with
the 3 and so you get our cost in this
circumstance is going to be 20 plus 8
times 3 or 20 plus 24 or 44 dollars so
let me erase this right over here so
this is going to cost us 44.
44. now let's do the same thing under
the trial plan how much is it going to
cost us to attend three sessions
well this is more straightforward or
slightly more straightforward our total
cost is going to be equal to 12
12 times the number of sessions the
number of sessions in this circumstance
are three sessions so it's going to be
times 3 so our total cost is going to be
equal to 36 dollars
so let me write that down so it's going
to be equal to 36 dollars but we could
also answer more interesting questions
with these equations for example how
many sessions
how many sessions
sessions
can i attend
can i attend in a month
attend
for
well i don't know let's throw out
something for 54.
for 54. let's say that's just my budget
when i look at my salary and how much
money i have budgeted to health and
fitness this is what i can afford and so
based on that i want to ask how many
sessions can i attend in each of these
situations so first let's think about it
for the trial plan how many sessions can
i attend for 54. and let's just assume
let's just assume that this is some type
of a special special yoga studio where
you can even attend half a session so if
you attend half a session they'll charge
you six dollars if you attend a fourth
of a session they'll charge you three
dollars so they'll actually keep track
of exactly what fraction of a session
you're attending so you can you don't
have to just attend whole number of
sessions you could attend two and a half
and they'll bill you accordingly so with
that said with that said how many
sessions under the trial plan can i
attend for fifty four dollars
well let's think about this a little bit
so my cost now is going to be fifty four
dollars fifty four dollars is c it's my
monthly cost so 54 is going to be equal
to 12
12 per session times the number of
sessions
times the number of sessions so now i
set up this equation in order to answer
this question i just need to figure out
what's the number of sessions that
satisfy it now the this s is an unknown
variable what number of sessions times
12 is equal to 54.
well you might say well if i could just
get a s just an s on the right hand side
here then i'll have an answer s will be
equal to some value and if i want just
an s on the right hand side i'd ideally
just like to divide
this by 12. 12s divided by 12 is just
going to give me an s it's just going to
give me the number of sessions
but if i have an equal sign i can't just
willy-nilly divide one side by 12
without doing the exact same thing to
the other side if that is equal to that
in order for them to both still be equal
i have to do the same thing to both
sides so on the right hand side
i'm left with just an s
and on the left hand side
i have 54 divided by 12. let me think
about that 12 goes into 54. i'll just
work it out
12 goes into 54
goes into 54 four times 4 times 12 is 48
you're left with a remainder of 6. so
you could say 12 goes into 5 12 goes
into 54 or you could say 54 over 12 is
equal to 4 and 6 12
or 4
and a half so the number of sessions
that i could attend are four and a half
under if i have 54 to spend i can attend
four and a half sessions under the trial
plan if this was a yoga studio that said
oh you can't attend half sessions then
it would then you could say well at most
i could attend four sessions because
five sessions would get me above my
budget but i said that you can attend
fractional sessions so we're going to
say four and a half
now let's do the same let's answer the
same question let's answer the same
question for the basic plan
under the basic plan how many sessions
can i attend for 54 dollars
well once again this is going to be our
cost our total cost for that month so we
say
54.
is equal to 20 plus 8 times the number
of sessions
plus 8 times
times the number of sessions and once
again i'd like to just have sessions
maybe on the right hand side of this
equation so i could say oh sessions are
going to be equal to something this is
the number of sessions that i can attend
but i have this 20 here and this 8 here
and so i have to think about how i can
get rid of them so the first thing i
think about is how can i get rid of this
20 from the right hand side of this
equation what am i going to have to do
to the entire equation
well the simplest thing is i could
subtract 20 from the right hand side
but if i subtract 20 from the right hand
side i also have to subtract 20 from the
left hand side in order to maintain the
equality
and so i'm left with on the left hand
side 54 minus 20 gets me 34
and that's going to be equal to well the
whole point of subtracting 20 is so that
these negate each other and then i have
just an 8s
it's just 8s so 8 times the number of
sessions has to be equal to 34 in order
for 8 times the number of sessions plus
20 to be equal to 54. and you could add
20 to both sides of this equation to get
our original
so we're almost done we just want to
isolate the s right here and you can
imagine the easiest way would to be to
divide the right hand side by 8 but if
we're dividing the right hand side by 8
we have to do the same to the left
and so what do we get for the number of
sessions that we would have to attend
well these cancel out and so you get the
number of sessions number of sessions is
equal to 34 divided by 8.
34 divided by 8 is equal to let's see 8
goes into 34 4 times with the remainder
2. so 4 and 2 8 or it's 4 and 1 4. so i
could attend 4 and one fourth sessions
under
under the basic plan
so under
assuming i can do fractional sessions
for 54 dollars which one can i attend
more sessions in the basic plan or the
trial plan
well for fifty four dollars i could
attend a slightly longer amount of
sessions under the trial plan